how are you steve are you doing you good
i'm doing good congrats on going
instagram official with blake
it's been it's thank you it's very
exciting moment for her
yeah why why wouldn't it be right
first of all you know i love this movie
this is one of my favorites of the year
i i can't say enough good things about
it um
and uh i just you know just throwing
that out there but you pulled off this
amazing reaction video of you as
deadpool
uh with taika how did you pull that off
you know you i asked really i mean at
the end of the day it just came down to
asking i
didn't think disney would say yes
because korg is not a cheap character
that is an expensive character to put on
screen for especially for a reaction
video um but
it did sort of you know all of it sort
of collided at this perfect sort of
intersection in disney's interests
so i i imagine that had something to do
with it but i initially asked them to do
a um
i wanted to actually i wrote it too a
short film that i wanted to put in front
of
free guy of deadpool interrogating
the hunter who killed bambi's mom and
the sort of rug pull
and they said no of course but the rug
pull of it was that deadpool really
wanted to know like the the hunter's
secrets on being like the most
loathed disney character there is
deadpool really wanted was just a huge
fan and wanted to find out how he too
could become the most loathed
uh disney character but they said no to
that uh so this became the kind of um
i don't even want to call it a
consolation prize because i think it's
so much better than that um to get to
work with
taika as korg for me was kind of a dream
come true
was there any resistance or was it when
you pitched it they're like yeah this is
great
yeah there was very little resistance
well i mean you you know it helps when
you write it all out first
and send it to them so they see exactly
what it is you don't just pitch it you
just kind of
uh show them um but no they were they
were on board
right away you know we we shot it quite
quickly after they greenlit
i don't think people understand who are
outside the industry
how hard it is nowadays to make
something original
that is not based on ip and have like a
real budget the way you guys have with
free guy
so for all the people that are looking
to do this in the future how the f did
you pull this off
well i mean it was a very very strong
story and a very strong premise
obviously pretty high concept but super
accessible it was super
funny had action had the gut punch of
emotion in it
but it's not easy and i don't you know i
don't pretend to have some kind of
secret
antidote or or or cure or sort of sort
of secret sauce to get something like
this made but they said yes
and we were super grateful for that um
you know and i grew up watching movies
that like back to the future
and indiana jones which you know before
they had sequels they were like these
you know
high concept really highly entertaining
uh original movies that blew me away and
took me away to another place and
i wanted to sort of be a part of
something that does that
you know and sean levy really certainly
wanted to be a part of something that
does that and
um with sean i found a unique and
hopefully lifelong creative partner in
that way i mean we're really lucky to be
able to say we just shot our second
uh movie together which we're in post on
now and then hopefully a third next year
so
um you know it was a unique situation
that really kind of paid off we're
really really lucky to get to make this
i love learning about the behind the
scenes the making of a film
and maybe learning things that people
wouldn't know what do you think might
surprise people to learn about the
making of free guy
you might be shocked to know just how
many utterly crazy easter eggs and
cameos are in this movie um i know
people have seen the movie two or three
times and still kind of haven't found
them all
um so that part i find really rewarding
i think when you make a movie like we
were just talking about that's
original and new and not based on
anything that audiences previously
knew or fans of you have to kind of you
have to adopt so many people but i think
that when you make a movie that that is
very very very good or you make a scene
that is perfect you then have to make it
30
better like somehow you have to like it
go so far
beyond good or perfect in order to make
the movie
really really land because you're
introducing audiences to something
that's totally new so
i love the detail that was put into
freak i love the cameos i love the
easter eggs i love all those things that
make it so special
i don't want to ruin anything but i have
seen the film twice and now i understand
or have found some of these secrets if
you will can you sort of talk about
how you got certain people to do some
voices
which i will not reveal in this
interview was it is it as simple as you
texting people being like do you want to
do this
yeah pretty much i mean you know it's
just it's
hollywood for all of its weirdness and
ups and downs it's still a community
you know you still know a lot of the
other people that work in the industry
i'm lucky to know some
heavy hitters as well and i thought i
could text and say hey would you do this
thing for me some of whom i've done that
for them you know and and cameos to me
are sort of like the great
hollywood hollywood exchange you know if
somebody asks me to do a cameo for their
movies
chances are unless i'm like in the
middle of shooting overseas or something
i'm
pretty much gonna say yes i'm gonna bend
over backwards to make it
work um and i'm really lucky to say that
that happened here on free guy people
jumped in
because they loved the premise and the
idea and the players involved and we got
a pretty cool array of heavy hitters to
to to be in the movie oh you did um i am
curious what's the status of this clue
movie that you might be doing with jason
bateman is this real
is it i don't know i mean i don't know
if we're going to end up ever getting
that made it's you know it's one of
those things that in the shuffle of
disney
you know acquiring fox i'm not quite
sure if we'll ever get to miss we'll see
hopefully down the road i love
jason bateman i couldn't be a bigger
jason bateman fan so
if it's not this it'll be something else
that hopefully we get to work on down
the road
you guys did a movie together that i
really like um
so obviously i need to ask you a few
questions about deadpool you know this
is coming
um so if you don't mind um what is the
percentage
chance that you actually could be
filming deadpool 3 next year
the percentage chance uh i don't know
i couldn't assign a percentage to that
um i'd say it's like 50
50 maybe i mean we're we're really
actively developing it and getting it
into pretty good shape so
um what's what the hell month is it it's
august oh next year probably pretty good
i don't know i'd say pretty damn good
i'd say 70 percent
yeah you made me nervous when you said
50 i'm like [ __ ] that's not
that's well i know but i i'm a person
who has absolutely a no sense of
direction
i'm i can i can get lost in a closet and
then b
i have no sense of time my wife will be
like wasn't that like in august that
that thing happened or july i'll be like
i i don't know of 1880
i can't i have no sense of time i'm
terrible you are
a very talented writer and i'm curious
how are you working
are collaborating if you will on the
script can you give people
like a status update uh
you know i i mean it's just it's it's
something that we just
is it is a daily process i mean writing
is kind of like that you gotta you gotta
a lot time to do it and then walk away
and and uh
um i'm working with the mongoose on it
it's been great they're
incredibly talented so so smart so
understand that world and
know how to zig when when everyone's
expecting a zag so
it's been uh it's been a lot of fun i'm
gonna switch to something else you're
currently filming with will ferrell
um yes sir and i could not be more
excited about this project because of
the two of you
uh what can you tease people about it
what was it about this script that said
i want to do this
uh well it's you know it's it's a
a musical for one which was to me was
completely unthinkable and terrifying
uh i don't think i think even three or
four years ago i probably wouldn't have
had the courage to say yes to it
um but you know i had the time to invest
and i think will as well
we both really had the time to invest in
learning in doing basically
song and dance camp which is kind of
what we did for
for months in advance of shooting and um
and i love learning something new and
will is a really has been a comedy idol
of mine for
i i couldn't even tell you a sign a
number of years but it's
at least 15 years he's been you know at
the sort of
pinnacle of comedy for me because he
sort of he always blends his comedy with
this vulnerability that i find so
fascinating um so to get to work with
him has been
nothing short of amazing and in person
he lives up to every
crazy ideal and standard i had for him
going in he's uh he's just an excellent
human being and i'm super lucky to work
with him
on that note congrats again on free guy
as i said one of the best films of the
year
thank you so much for your time thanks
steve i appreciate it all right take it
easy